[Music]
foreign
and thank you for joining us I'm Trey
Gowdy happy Easter and welcome to Sunday
night in America we start with the
border which remains a chaotic crisis
there are National Security and law
enforcement and public health concerns
many Americans are not happy with the
situation at the border and then that
becomes a political concern especially
for Democrats heading into the midterms
it has been a long-standing open
invitation any Republican who wants to
work with us on immigration reform
you're invited but I think it's clear
what we're seeing from Republicans is an
effort to politicize this and not fix
what we all recognize as an outdated and
broken system
an open invitation you say the
invitation I most vividly recall was
actually extended back in 2020 by
Democrat presidential candidates
including Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
to come to the southern border you go
back and listen to the rhetoric from the
candidates
they didn't want border security they
didn't want to make it a crime to cross
the border unlawfully they had a hard
time finding anyone they actually wanted
to deport and now they call the system
broken and they want Republicans to help
fix it but Democrats don't need
Republican help remember Democrats
control the house the Senate and the
White House Democrats don't need
legislative help they need political
help they need help deflecting the blame
for the crisis at the border the math is
pretty simple the number of people
showing up at the border seeking entry
into this country is historically high
and it will only get higher in the
spring and summer months and of course
there's a war in Eastern Europe and some
of those fleeing that war will also wind
up at the border Democrats have used
immigration as a campaign issue for
Years first to attract support among
Hispanic voters and then to attract
support among voters and this country
sympathetic to the plight of those
wanting to come to this country we're
all sympathetic to those seeking a
better life America is generous and
America is welcoming more so than any
other country in the world most of all
America is a nation of laws and right
now it's hard to see the law through the
chaos at the border there will be a
political price to pay for that
come November hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else